you're not going to be allowed to bring
that triangle that you've already drawn
for your exercise you're not going to be
allowed to bring that into an assessment
sir are you going to have to recreate
the trail or every single time when you
get given something like seven or eight
or nine or something even more visual
the answer is no so there's a button on
here that I'm going to get to in a
second but I want to generalize for you
what is happening here now how I said to
you every single time every single term
in the expansion has these one two or
three components okay every single time
so let's generalize this I'm going to
say a generalization is when you take a
specific idea or a specific instance of
something that's a what does it look
like for any value of this or any value
of this or any value of that right so
I'm going to generalize it completely in
fact is giving a very similar to this a
plus B cubed if I have a plus B but I
raise it take any positive integer power
M okay what is it going to be equal to
right now every single time you can see
there are three components let's do the
two components that are easier first if
you've got an ATAR beam right you've got
an end of it you've got some number of
these and some number of these right so
what's the very first term going to have
how many
Ami's will have an having B's well at
this time I started with five and zero
right in this case it would be five
it'll be and so I'm gonna have n of
those and I'm going to have Wellman have
none of those okay that's two of the
three components this third can pretty
here I need some way of describing there
are two qualities that I get this wrong
right number one there are how many
coefficients on it that expansion
nothing there are six of those
coefficients I can see 1 5 10 10 5 1
okay so the first thing you need to know
is well okay which coefficient a my
attitude is it the first one or the
second one or the third or fourth
six on the enth one okay so number one I
need to describe which coefficient you
looking at then secondly I need to know
why is it 1 5 10 10 5 1 why is it not 1
6 15 25th
why is it not that one how did I know
which road to pick it's cuz of the power
right it's this guy up here so the first
thing you need to know is which which
item along there are am i and then
secondly you need to know which row are
you okay so here's the way we're going
to introduce some notation I want to say
I want the in throw in Pascal's triangle
so I'm gonna write the number in which
of the which is the terms do 1 1 well
this is the in a real way this is the
zeroeth term okay I when you think about
how many terms there are going to be all
up if I cut them like this 0 1 2 3 4 5
if you start at 0 by the time you get to
the end there are 6 coefficients do you
see and you end on the same power that
you're supposed to end on right the same
one that you started good up here so I'm
gonna say the number 0 these are the two
numbers that are important to me that's
what row I am that's which term on the
row I am and they be in between there if
we put a safe now it's a little bit
mysterious as to why we use the letter C
that mystery will be solved by the time
we get to the end of this topic okay but
for now I want to show you that notation
there is an alternative way to write up
maybe just right up here you'll see it
sometimes written without this letter C
but instead with a pair of brackets and
the same pair of numbers there okay so
the number the top is which role of
Pascal's triangle
and the second number is which term in
the row are you particularly interested
so that's the notation and that's just
the first term but what the next term
which were Pascal's triangle
am I on I'm still on the end rows right
that hasn't changed because it's the
same expansion it's not this tower
that's not changing midway through so
I'm going to write n I'm gonna write
this see down here and now on the next
term along well the next time after zero
is the the first right so I'm gonna
write this and I actually say it out and
see what now what happens to the powers
do you listen to the for now this is a 1
so speaking more generally what happens
to the index the powerful a it's gonna
be n minus 1 isn't it just drops down 1
from whatever it was before so this will
be an N to the N minus 1 how many beats
like a half and that's a whole second
turn now to establish a patent it's
usually customary to say we need three
terms the reason why is because if I say
to you one two dot you don't really know
what the next term is it could either be
three which would make sense so it's one
two three four five or it could be for
what would the next one be if it was 4
then 8 then 16 32 et cetera so only two
terms and this will become very
important when we learn a topic called
series and sequences only two terms not
enough to set up a pan you need a third
one so let's just put on the next term
you can help me out now what's the
binomial coefficient going a and C 2
that's just how I read it or
alternatively I could write it and you
will see me in the future I will more
frequently write it like this party
because I'm lazy and it requires less
than slightly was right
it's the same notation you need to be
able to recognize both how many A's will
I have a to them mostly just one less
than what I had before
how many B's okay now this is only the
first two terms I don't know how many
terms there are right so I just kind of
have to say dot dot dot until such times
I finish but it does finish somewhere
this isn't loaded forever how many times
are they going to be the number of terms
is going to be n plus one because if for
example it's fine then you can have one
two three four five six terms okay but
the final term because I started with
zero the final term in terms of this
counting system if you go zero one two
just like I went zero one two the last
one I'm going to call the IMP term even
though if I count a lot there n plus one
I know that's a little bit weird but it
makes this final term really easy to
write let me run this office on your
space the last time will be I'm still on
the same row of Pascal's triangle and
see remember I said you're going to end
on the number that you're supposed to
have up in the tower right so this will
be n s'i and if I had started counting
from 1 instead of 0 this would be NEC n
plus 1 which is a little bit women like
I want to finish on a nice symmetrical
thing so that's the final binomial
coefficient by the time I get to the
last time how many days are left
none of them a to the 0 and by the time
I get to the end just like here all the
B's are taken over and I shouldn't have
exactly
so that's the expansion